Let's continue our ongoing quiz. This instruction has issued. We have issued
it in cycle 1. It begins executing in cycle 2 because these operands are ready.
The result is going to be 20 over 5, so the result is going to be 4. And
that result will become available in 2 plus 10. That
result will be broadcast in cycle 12. And this makes us ready to begin cycle 2.
At the beginning of cycle 2, this reservation station is already freed. And
we will try to issue this instruction. That instruction will be issued by
finding a reservation station and a ROB entry. We will write R1. R5 and
R6 are going to come from the register file, are going to be four and
two. The result will broadcast under the name of ROB2 and
we have issued this instruction in cycle 2. In cycle 2 also,
the execution of this instruct, of the first instruction has begun. In cycle 3,
we will issue the next instruction and begin executing this one.
So what happens in cycle 4 is we have issued this instruction,
it's operands were ready already, so at the beginning of cycle 4,
this reservation station is free. That instruction has begun execution. And,
we will consider now issuing this multiplication here. The question for
you regarding this multiplication is, what is going to be here, here,
here, and here? So what is going to be in the reservation station for
the multiplication once we have issued it. And
we do issue it in the fourth cycle. And also, which RAT entry,
put the register number, is going to be modified as a result of this? So
which RAT entry, is it R1, R2, R3, or which one?